I am in love with this dog.
In love.
[INAUDIBLE] demon up there
on the shelves. [INAUDIBLE].
Oh, we're on?
Yes?
What's up, everyone?
Welcome to this Google
Hangout over here.
My name is Jason Silva.
And in case you
guys are not aware,
I create, in
partnership with my pals
at Revision3, Shots of Awe.
Shots of Awe is a weekly series
of short nuggets of techno
rapture that celebrate
big ideas, that
celebrate inspiration,
that celebrate
those moments that [?
we ?] make final cuts.
I am an inspiration junkie.
I love to be elated.
And I'm here to take your
questions and chat with you
about YouTube.com/ShotsofAwe.
I'm also the host of Brain Games
on National Geographic Channel.
And I'm excited that
you guys are here.
And I'm open to all of it.
I'm hearing a playback right
now of what I just recorded.
It's already playing back.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
What's up, everyone?
Welcome to this--
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
OK.
There we go.
All right, everyone.
Sorry.
Technical failure.
We actually had a power
failure at the office
where we were going to do this.
Human technology, co-evolution
collapsed ironically.
Here I am talking about
singularity, and we lost power.
Anyway, ask away.
I'm here for you.
Let's chat.
Let's create a techno-social
wormhole of communication
and transcend time,
space and distance.
All right?
OK.
Oh.
"Can you speak on
the possibility
of a dystopian singularity?
What are the potential
threats of a Utopian future?"
Sure.
Look, I think Kurzweil has
talked about this a lot
as well.
Technology has always
been a double-edged sword.
Technology extends
our reach, but it
can extend our reach
in any direction.
Perhaps the man that discovered
fire, as Kurzweil says,
was probably burned at the
stake by his contemporaries.
So we can use fire
to cook our foods,
or we can use fire
to burn one another.
So we use these tools,
we use these instruments,
to extend the boundaries of
our thought, of our reach,
of our vision, to
extend ourselves.
But it's how we choose
to extend ourselves
that ultimately determines
the effect that technology
has on our future.
And I think that's where
cultural narratives are
important.
That's where memes
are important.
That's where, again, these
narratives that will ultimately
inform how we use these
tools are crucial.
So that's what publishing
platforms like TED
are so important.
That's why I make my videos,
to put them out there,
to inspire a greater
vision of life, a greater
vision of what's possible.
But if you actually
map out human progress
over the last 100 years,
contrary to popular belief,
we have to used these
tools to make life better.
Steven Pinker's work
talks about the fact
that the chances of a man dying
at the hands of another man
today are the lowest
than they've ever been.
The world has actually never
been less violent than it is
today, contrary
to popular belief.
So it's not utopia yet,
but it's leaning that way,
as Steven Johnson likes to say.
More questions.
Let's see.
"What are the actions you can
take beyond reading and talking
about this kind of
awesome vision?"
Well, I think use the
tools at your disposal
to basically put out your unique
vision, add it to the world.
We've never had such
tools with which
to create ripples
that can transform.
It's this idea that a
young person with a cell
phone in Africa today
has better communications
technology in the US
president had 25 years ago.
So how might this young
child use this tool?
How might he use it to
extend his creativity?
To remix his fear
of possibilities?
It's not my job, I
think, to tell you
how or what you can do.
It's mostly just to inspire
you to believe that you can.
But I think you have
to ultimately discover
your own path.
What is your
contribution going to be?
That, I think, is the question
we can all ask ourselves.
In fact, at Singularity
University in Silicon Valley,
they've created this whole
university at the NASA Ames
campus to encourage
and teach people
to think exponentially
about what's possible.
The idea is that passionate
individuals today
can do what only governments
and corporations used
to do mere decades ago.
The tools to change the world
are in everybody's hands.
I think that's a wonderful idea.
Because on the back
of these exponentials,
you are now more empowered
than you've ever been.
So again, the question is,
what is your contribution
going to be?
Let's see.
"can The Matrix be considered
a controlled singularity?"
Yeah.
I think The Matrix was presented
as a dystopian meditation
on control and free
will and identity,
because dystopian stories
and conflicts make
more entertaining movies.
But a lot of stuff that was
hypothesized in that film
sounds pretty glorious.
Wouldn't you like to inhabit
a kind of virtual world,
indistinguishable from
this one, but one in which
the very physics, the very
constructs of said reality
are completely malleable?
Why can't we all be
Neos in The Matrix.
Why can't we all
move into universes
of our own construction?
Terence McKenna says the
man made world is already
a condensation of
the imagination.
The whole thing has been
sprouted from the human mind.
In the film The Matrix, I
didn't see it as a bad thing,
for us to live in
this virtual utopia.
But the film found it
necessary to say, oh,
humans didn't accept the
program when it was perfect.
They only accepted it when there
was conflict, nah, nah, nah,
nah, nah, and then it went
off in that other direction.
But yeah, that's kind
of a singularity.
The minute you can
create an AI that
can build a world for
you, that's a singularity.
Why not?
"Have you read Radical
Evolution by Joel Garreau?"
Heard of it.
Read pieces of it.
Haven't read the whole thing.
"How cool is it to be on
the Joe Rogan podcast?"
I love Joe Rogan.
I think that he's got
something really amazing
with that podcast.
It's a labor of love.
He produces it with his friends.
They blast it out into
the world, unedited.
And they touch on such
a range of topics.
From MMA, to
consciousness expansion,
to the technological
singularity.
He's had everybody from Sam
Harris to comedians to me.
It's an absolute honor to
have been there three times.
And the response that I got
from appearing on the Joe Rogan
podcast has been superb.
The passionate nature of
his fans and his followers
is humbling, but it's
wonderful at the same time.
"Have you thought about
writing a book any time soon?"
I've actually been contacted
by several publishers and book
agents, believe it or not.
Ever since my
videos going viral,
and doing all the
keynotes around the world,
and also Brain Games, that I
host on National Geographic,
has been the highest
rated series launch
in the history of
NatGeo as well.
So all these things kind
of happened at once.
I've been experiencing my
own singularity, in a way.
With Shots of Awe and the
Brain Games and speaking.
And so people have
started to approach me
about writing a book.
And I've hesitated a little bit.
Because a part of
me feels like, I
believe in remix
and mash-up culture.
I'm not really an academic.
So my book would be essay-istic.
It would be a stream of
consciousness of the references
and the anchor points of
the frameworks of reality
that I'm currently surfing.
If people are expecting
an academic book,
that's not what they're
going to get from me.
I have this fantasy of doing a
coffee table book with images
from the Imaginary Foundation
mixed with my favorite essays.
So it's more of a
curatorial effort, where
I would grab selections from
Terence McKenna and Timothy
Leary and Erik Davis and then
images form the Imaginary
Foundation, and then
maybe some pictures-- just
beatific other images
that I stumbled upon.
That would be awesome.
"Transcend time
and space, you say.
This will be fun."
Well, yeah.
That's kind of what these
technologies allow us to do.
Something I've
been thinking about
lately is how we
use airplanes force
us to re-accommodate ourselves,
to renegotiate our relationship
to distance and to
time and to scale.
What is close and
what is far when it
takes three hours in traffic
to get from uptown to downtown,
but then three hours
can also take you
to another side
of the continent?
These machines, they transform
all notions of scale,
all notions of distance.
But psychologically, it's
still a re-accomodation, right?
I feel very disjointed when
I take these long trips,
because there's something
just supernatural, almost,
about these magical machines
that fly through the sky,
and we somehow take
it for granted.
Amber Case, the
cyborg anthropologist,
says that even right now, here
in a techno-social wormhole,
we've created this
hole in space and time.
And wherever you guys
are, you can hear me,
you can talk to
me, I can hear you.
The human mind--
at least the part
of the mind that is
communicating-- communication
itself between
sentient minds has
transcended time,
space and distance.
I think that's unbelievable.
"Virtual reality is coming.
Any worlds in particular
you would like to visit?"
Oh my god, yeah.
I want to visit Jodie Foster's
wormhole in the movie Contact,
when she's literally
riding a roller
coaster through the universe.
That would be rad.
Also, the Utopian romantic
projection of Cameron Crowe's
Vanilla Sky.
The lucid dream where the
character of David Aames
creates this virtual, lucid
dream that's sculpted out
of the iconography of his youth.
So images of pop culture,
references of love,
of what love is like, of
what friendship is like,
all these things that
inform his lucid dream.
Like a virtual space
that's rendered
at the speed of your
thoughts-- or rather,
your fantasies--
sounds pretty rad.
To create and perceive your
world at the same time,
like the dream
sequences in Inception.
How awesome would that be?
"What is your take on aliens?"
Well, I think that
it is inevitable
that intelligent life either
will be or has evolved
somewhere else in the universe.
My intuition tells me, it's
too big, it's too bast,
the scales are too
difficult of fathom
for there not to be something
else like what occurred here.
Whether they've visited us
or not, I'm not convinced.
Most UFO footage
looks like a hoax.
Whether panspermia was
responsible for putting life
on Earth, whether the building
blocks of life were sent here.
That idea of panspermia
is kind of amazing.
Especially because Freeman
Dyson, the physicist,
says we need to do that soon.
We need to take all the
DNA of life on Earth
and send it out into space.
So who knows?
Maybe some intelligent
super alien intelligence
did that to seed the
life on this planet.
It's interesting
to speculate about.
I love the mystery of that,
the possibility of that.
There's an interesting
thing called
the transcension hypothesis
that I made a video about that
tries to explain
Fermi's Paradox, which
is if the universe is
so vast, why don't see
any evidence of these
extraterrestrial civilizations?
And the reason is that as
complexity and technology
evolves, we stop
expanding outwards,
and we start expanding inwards.
The whole thing about STEM
compression-- the compression
of space, time,
energy, and matter--
means we start to put more
computation and more complexity
into denser and denser spaces.
Until you have
computation at the level
of the nano scale
and the femto scale.
And literally, you're
concentrating [INAUDIBLE]
into a point where
you literally create
black hole-like conditions,
and virtual realities
and digital minds disappear
into those black hole-like
conditions and
slingshot to the end
of the universe, the
end of space-time.
And that's where all the other
extraterrestrial civilizations
are.
And so that's why we
don't see them anywhere,
because they exist outside
of the observable universe.
Because of this inevitable
STEM compression
that happens when technology
reaches that singularity.
That's why we can't
see the aliens.
Maybe.
"Because of
mortality, our brains
help us make decisions
to keep us alive
because we are afraid to die.
What do you think
our world would
be like without
these limitations?"
I think about Robert Ettingter,
who wrote Man into Superman.
And he says, "together
we shall taste
the wine of centuries unborn."
Nobody's going to
convince me with
the deathist rationalization
that says that, oh, death gives
meaning to life and we would
be bored if we were immortal.
I'm sorry, man.
I think that that's just
because we are poetic
and we've found a way
to accommodate ourselves
to personal extinction.
But I [INAUDIBLE] words
of Alan Harrington
that says, "any philosophy
that accepts death must itself
be considered dead, its
questions meaningless,
its consolations worn out."
I'm sorry.
Just nobody's going
to convince me
to accept the
inevitability of loss,
the inevitability of losing
everyone I care about.
I just do not accept.
I just defy those conditions.
I do not accept those terms.
I love too much.
I love my family.
I love the people in my life.
And I just don't accept
that this imposition,
this entropy thing, says oh,
love each other for as long
as you can, because you're
going to be food for worms.
Not cool.
And I think the purpose
of human evolution
is the trend to end entropy.
Is to basically engineer
our own divinity.
That's what it
means to be human.
To transcend all
previous limits.
I think we can talk about
anything. [INAUDIBLE] metaphor.
You can talk about unknowable
things using metaphors.
Even singularity
is a physics term.
It's a physics term borrowed
to describe this even horizon,
this moment in which AI become
smarter than the human brain.
And so thinking itself
takes on a dimension
that is unfathomable to human
brains without augmentation.
The whole idea of it is
that we use language,
we use poetry to
describe the ineffable.
That's another great skill
set that we happen to have.
So I do think we could speculate
about what the singularity--
how it might play out.
But sure, to imagine
what it will be like
is as difficult as trying
to imagine what the world
post-language would have
been too early hominids
on the other side of that line.
Try to explain to
chimp the nuances
of a Shakespearean sonnet.
You know what I mean?
It's not that easy.
They don't have
the mental software
to be able to run
that in their heads.
Which is a shame, because
they're missing out.
"Hawking says that if we
don't back up humanity--"
Yeah, look.
We have backups for our iPhones.
We need to back
up our mind file.
We need to back up our DNA.
We need to back up humanity.
I do think that, yeah, we
need to back ourselves up.
Why wouldn't we?
What a tragic thing it
would be to not be backed up
and be hit by a train.
Oh.
I can't imagine
anything more horrible.
What else we got?
Your response, can we even
talk mortality-- The internet
already being an AI.
Well, there's a great
metaphor, of course,
that says as we all join the
internet-- in terms of scale
and emergence-- just like
10 trillion cells decided
to team up and become
the super-organism called
the human being, now
billions of human beings
are teaming up and becoming
this super-organism called
the internet, and the
internet is wiring all of us
together like
individual synapses.
And these synapses are
becoming this global brain.
And that eventually,
when there's
sufficient interconnection
and sufficient complexity,
a new kind of
planetary consciousness
might emerge from that.
And it's one of those
things where you can't plan.
That's the whole
thing about emergence.
[INAUDIBLE] complexity leads
to something different.
The sum of the parts adds
up to more than the parts.
That is what emergence is.
So even if that
did happen, I don't
know if we would be aware
of it, the very same way
that the cells that make up the
individual cells in my bodies
probably are not aware
that their aggregate is
this super-organism.
So yeah.
The internet could
lead to that, but I
don't know if we
would be aware of it.
Wow.
"Man will not merely
endure-- he will prevail."
Oh, wow.
William Faulkner said,
man will not just
endure-- he will prevail.
I love that!
That's a beautiful thing.
That's like the guy that said,
"first we build the tools,
then they build us."
He also said that he's
confident that men
will learn the songs that
orchestrate the universe.
Look at us.
We're a pretty
exceptional species.
Our ability to reverse
engineer reality.
I look at what
we've done so far,
and it makes me think
there's nothing we can't do.
I think it was Sophocles who
says "Manifold the wonders.
Nothing towers more
wondrous than man."
I agree.
I think it's sad that a lot
of people fail to see that.
But I think it's my mission
in life to get them to see it.
Besides, what is life if
not the pursuit of a dream?
The dream of transcendence,
the dream of glory,
the dream of usurping
all previous limits.
Row, row, row your boat
gently down the stream.
Merrily, merrily,
merrily, merrily.
Life is but a dream."
What else?
Plato's Allegory of the Cave.
Ooh.
That's a good one.
"I love the amount of
enthusiasm you have.
What inspired you to be an
influential type of speaker?"
Interesting.
Thank you for that.
I didn't plan to have
a speaking career.
I worked at Current, Al Gore's
TV network, for four years.
And I was hosting
a show on Current.
And when I left, I
wanted to go back
to create the kind of content
that moved me profoundly,
which was content that reflected
my philosophical sensibilities
and my love
aesthetically-relevant
presentation.
And I started doing these
short videos, the Philosophical
Espresso Shots, as a way
of creating a visual art
form, a format, so to speak,
a short form communication
style that was built
around how I talk.
I just so happen to go on
these rants for two minutes.
If you hang out
with me, you'll see.
And so I thought,
eh, maybe I can
take some of my most lucid
rants on my favorite ideas
and edit them with
music and imagery
and put people in
my head to turn
my subjectivity into a visual,
externalized art you could see.
So it's like you could see
my [? thoughts ?], you could
see the butterfly
effect in thought as I
was going through it.
And the videos took off.
And what happened is
people would see the work,
people would see the videos.
It was a way of
discovering these ideas ,
which is ultimately
what these were about.
Trailers for ideas.
And then I got to speak
at the Singularity Summit
and I had really good
feedback from that.
And then I spoke at another
economist ideas conference
and I had really good
feedback from that.
Then I found out I
have a knack for it.
Because I'm so passionate
about these ideas
that it flowed very naturally.
Then TED Global came to me.
Of course, the illustrious
TED Conference, so amazing.
They had me do a video for them
called Radical Openness which
I premiered on the TED stage.
And from that, things
just snowballed.
I've since spoken at the
Festival of Dangerous Ideas
in the Sydney Opera
House, which was amazing.
I've done corporate keynotes for
IBM, and Intel, and Microsoft,
and Adobe, and Oracle.
It's taken off.
And I'm just really
grateful, because it's
like Joseph Campbell
used to say,
"follow your bliss
and doors will
open where there were no doors."
And that's kind of how it feels.
It's really wild.
It's like that
scene in The Matrix
when Neo has that realization
that he can see the code
and he can rewrite the code.
And a lot of these limitations
and these frameworks of reality
are just that.
They're software
that can be hacked.
I love the term
"reality hacking."
The only thing standing
in your way is you.
It's a big idea.
Big idea.
"The idea of overcoming entropy.
Humans can influence
chaos and organize it
with nothing but our minds.
What do you think?"
I completely buy
into that notion.
I think entropy is an
existential bummer.
I think that life
is anti-entropic,
as Bucky Fuller used to say.
We move towards
greater complexity.
We don't accept these
existential bummers
if we don't have to.
And we've already doubled
the human lifespan.
And that was before the
revolutions and domestication
of biotechnology.
I was just watching that
video of that little girl
that was cured from cancer
by them putting HIV in her.
They reprogrammed
the HIV virus so
that it would attack
her cancer cells.
Talk about hacking
the software of life.
Literally, they made the
virus attack her cancer cells
and she got cured.
There's nothing
we can't do, man.
We are as gods.
Love it.
"What's on your hat?
Are you ever in Venice?"
Actually, it says
"deus ex machina."
If the "s" in the
"deus" was an "x,"
it would be "god
in the machine."
So I discovered this company.
I was in Australia, and I have
another one that says "deus ex
machina," the god
is in the machine.
I thought it would
be funny because I
talk about the
singularity, and that's
like engineering divinity.
So that's where that comes from.
"Would you consider cloning
yourself when possible?
Ha, ha, ha.
Wow, thanks.
I haven't thought
about that yet.
I think that sure, that
would be interesting.
I haven't thought
about it, but yeah.
"If you were going
to college nowadays
to study science,
technology, which field
would you pursue because
of the current potential?"
I think anything.
Any of these emerging
technologies.
Anything that's
emerging exponentially.
I would encourage people to
go Singularity University,
actually, where they
focus on exponentials.
Exponential thinking,
I think, is key.
Because we have these
brains that just
intuitively think linearly.
But progress is exponential.
So we need to reprogram our
brains to think exponentially.
Venus project!
Yes, I'm aware of it.
Love the artwork for it.
It looks amazing.
It looks beautiful.
Jacque Fresco,
definitely a smart guy.
I think it's cool.
I think all possible
Utopian visions
are worth investigating and
pursuing in some capacity.
Just the idea of us trying to
create perfection turns me on.
"The future is already here.
It's just unevenly distributed."
Yeah.
People talk about
this all the time.
They say, yeah, these
technologies sound great.
But what about the info-nots?
You have the info-haves,
and you have the info-nots.
Kurzweil answered
this brilliantly.
He says, people are afraid
these technologies are only
for the rich.
And he answers, yeah,
like cellphones, right?
When cell phones
were first created,
they were expensive, clunky,
didn't work very well,
and perhaps only a
few could afford them.
Today, a young person
with a cellphone in Africa
has better communications
technology than the US
president had 25 years ago.
So these technologies,
they improve exponentially.
They get cheaper, they
get more accessible,
and they get more affordable.
So I don't think these
technologies are just
for the rich at all.
I think they spread and they
become available to everyone.
"What is your take on
vibrational [? seet ?]
frequency, multiverses,
ascension?"
I can't speak too much
about any of those other
than the multiverse idea.
The parallel universe
theory of quantum mechanics
that was proposed
by Hugh Everett III
is this idea that the only
way to explain quantum physics
is to assume that every possible
thing that could ever possibly
happen is happening in some kind
of parallel universe to ours.
There was a great book
called The Man who
Turned into Himself,
which took that idea
and wrote a fictional
account of it.
This guy, his wife dies, and
he just can't bear the pain.
And somehow, he learns to surf
between parallel universes.
And he ends up going to
the other parallel universe
in which his wife didn't die,
and then gets to be with her.
It's an amazing story.
Also, Michael
Crichton's book Timeline
use the parallel universe
theory of quantum mechanics
to achieve time travel.
Because obviously, I can't go
to the past of this universe,
but I can go to a parallel
universe in which their present
looks a lot like what
our past looked like.
And in order to get to
that parallel universe,
you can't fit human
through a wormhole.
But you can send a fax.
The same way you can't
put a piece of paper
through a telephone line,
but you can send a fax.
So they figure out how to scan
the information equivalent
of the human being,
destroy the human
on this side at the same
time as they zap you
through the wormhole.
And then the other
universe reconstructs you
upon receiving your
particles, somehow.
You self-organize, and you
just pop out the other side.
It's an idea, but
kind of a wild idea.
But Michael Crichton
in Timeline explored it
in a pretty cool way.
I can't believe I
actually remembered that.
How are we doing?
"Who are some of your idols?"
I adore Kevin Kelly's writings.
He's brilliant.
What Technology Wants is genius.
I like Terence McKenna's
ideas of a new university
that engenders novelty.
I like Timothy Leary, who
says that our technology is
the literalization of the
psychedelic dream of mind
expansion.
I really like film directors.
Cameron Crowe, who did
Vanilla Sky, is an idol.
Danny Boyle, who did Slumdog
Millionaire, 127 Hours, Trance,
The Beach, he's a total idol.
Ron Howard, who I've recently
become friends, total idol.
Apollo 13, A Beautiful
Mind, his new film Rush.
Love these guys.
Christopher Nolan,
who did Inception.
Oh my god.
I do think that filmmakers
are ecstatic shamans.
They take us to places of
ecstatic illuminations.
They're masters of
the art of capturing
and managing attention.
They can orient our awareness
to psychological spaces,
to subjective spaces
of grand visions
and grand possibilities.
I love those guys.
"What do you think of David
Pearce's idea of utopia?"
I love David Pearce.
I love him.
His Hedonistic Imperative,
I think, is brilliant.
Everybody should check that out.
It's this online treatise on
how we should use biotechnology,
nanotechnology, to engineer
suffering out of existence.
Like physical suffering.
Like pain, malaise,
death, disease.
Literally eliminate it.
And just literally
transform ourselves.
Like caterpillars turning
themselves into butterflies.
It plays out in nature.
Why can't we do it?
We are nature, too.
That's a thing you
shouldn't forget.
We are nature.
Everything we do is nature.
OK.
If you guys are enjoying
this conversation,
I would ask you to go to
YouTube.com/ShotsofAwe
and subscribe to my channel.
Because we're popping out
new videos every week.
Every week, I'm putting in
a new Shots of Awe video.
I'm working with
my friends here.
They're awesome.
The images, the music, the
micro-psychedelic experience.
It's like downloading
the universe.
So please, please subscribe.
YouTube.com/ShotsofAwe.
Also, follow me on Twitter.
I'm @JasonSilva.
S-I-L-V-A. @JasonSilva.
I have a verified account.
I'm easy to find.
Follow me on Twitter
and stay connected
so we keep this kind of
two-way conversation going.
Keep the techno-social
wormhole open.
Keep it stable.
Prediction of Moore's law
that exponential growth
will decelerate.
I don't think so.
I think that every
time the people are
afraid that Moore's Law or
that the exponentials are going
to stabilize, there is
a new paradigm shift.
Some new crazy
technology comes online,
and Moore's Law just continues.
Even gene sequencing is
going three times faster
than Moore's Law at the moment.
So I don't think
it's going to stop.
On the last Joe Rogan
concept, I touched on comedy
being a kind of philosophy.
Could you elaborate?
Yes, Well, comedians are the
original stand-up philosophers.
Or at least, the contemporary
stand-up philosophers.
There's not a lot of
spaces today outside
of university campuses
where somebody can stand up
and pontificate on things.
I try to do it in my talks.
But comics like Joe Rogan, like
George Carlin, like Bill Maher,
these are contemporary
philosophers.
They get up on stage
and they think out loud.
And they ruminate with you.
And they share anecdotes
and make observations
about the world.
They philosophize.
And then they have
this humorous twist.
We laugh because we
relate to what they're
saying, because they
mirror us brilliantly.
So I definitely
think that comedians
are contemporary
stand-up philosophers.
Technology, extension
of ourselves,
reflection of ourselves,
our true potential.
Look, I think technology,
again, is our second skin.
It's like the termite colony
is temperature controlled,
but it's still part of
the termite species.
The spider's web, it's
still part of the spider.
We need to think of our cities,
our skyscrapers, and our jet
engines as literally things
that are spilling over
out of the organism.
If we were able to
time lapse progress,
it would look like
our grand visions
and our grand dreams spill
over from our brains.
This is the world
that we live in.
This is what we are.
Well, guys.
This has been fun.
I tire easily because I'm very
passionate, as you can tell.
But I've had a great
time chatting with you.
And I hope that you
guys will subscribe
to YouTube.com/ShotsofAwe.
Follow me on Twitter
on @JasonSilva.
And tune into Brain Games on
National Geographic, which
is airing in the US
as well as the UK.
And in September,
in 100 countries.
So watch Brain Games on NatGeo.
Thanks a lot, guys.
Jason Silva, Shots
of Awe, signing off.
See you soon.